AMR ABDELRAZIK: Hi,
everyone, and thanks
for joining us today.
Today we're going to talk about
running Anthos on bare metal
at the edge with
Major League Baseball.
My name is Amr Abdelrazik.
I'm a product manager at Google
Cloud as part of the Anthos
team, and I'm here with
my friend, Kris Amy,
from Major League Baseball.
KRIS AMY: Hi, Amr.
Thanks for having me on today.
I run the team at
MLB that covers off
all the infrastructure for
our fan-facing services
which run on Anthos
and the Google Cloud.
I look forward to showing
you what we've got to offer.
AMR ABDELRAZIK: Awesome.
Thank you, Kris.
So the first question
is, why the edge and why
are we talking about the edge?
So customers are demanding
a more connected experience,
and this is happening
across different sectors,
whether it is retail,
connected factories, health
care, and even gaming.
What this means is enterprises
need to deploy applications
in many places,
whether from the left
you're looking at something
at the very far edge, hundreds
of thousands of sites, very low
latency, very small footprint.
And some of the
use cases of that
is real time control,
industrial security real time.
Or you get something
like the near edge, where
you have less
sites, probably less
sensitivity on the
latency, and you're
looking at something like
video and image analysis
and processing.
Or you go more to looking at
the traditional data center
core or cloud.
And the challenge is, how do
you deploy across all of these?
And this is hard,
because as you're
looking to deploy across
all of these applications,
you're looking at
migrating applications.
The developers are deploying
applications differently.
Every cloud or every
site is different.
You need to deploy the
application multiple times.
You can't move everything
to every location,
so it is just hard to
try to manage across all
of these infrastructure.
And the good news
is there is actually
a perfect storm of
opportunity about some
of the technologies
happening in the market that
have been happening over
the last couple of months.
So the first one, of
course, is 5G, but also
a lot of connectivity
options that are out there
that is improving connectivity,
latency, and bandwidth
for those edge scenarios.
The second one is
containers, when
you have a portable
application form
factor that allows you to deploy
across different environments
with ease.
And finally, there
is the open source,
the continuous innovation
with no vendor lock-in,
led by Kubernetes and
many other technologies
that are out there
in the markets.
So this presents a
great opportunity
to use all these new innovations
and leverage your existing data
and deliver your applications
to where you want.
So we [? have ?] a little bit
of a how can Anthos help you
with this problem.
So Anthos is our platform for
application modernization.
It allows you to
run on Google Cloud,
on premise, on other cloud
providers, or at the edge.
And the idea is Anthos gives you
managed operation, the service
management part, and the
marketplace and commerce
so that you can even add more
applications from third party
providers.
And Anthos gives you
multiple deployment options
from cloud platform, as we
discussed, vSphere, AWS.
You can even bring
your own Kubernetes,
or you can deploy it on bare
metal edge scenarios and Azure
that is coming soon.
So across all of these options,
Anthos [? provide ?] you
the deployment flexibility to
deploy application anywhere
and have the consistency of
your operational workflow
and your developer workflow.
So we're going to talk
a little about Anthos
on bare metal, a
technical overview, which
is our newest offering
that we announced recently.
So the idea for
Anthos on bare metal
is you can run Anthos on a
customer-provided operating
system.
In this scenario, you
can install Anthos
where the customer deploys
and manages the OS lifecycle.
You have pre-flight checks to
validate the minimum system
requirements, and then you
have idempotent and declarative
installer for all
Anthos components.
[? While ?] you can run it
from a compute capacity,
you can deploy
this on a physical
or a virtual infrastructure.
Now we expect most
of our customers
to run this on physical
server, but running
on your choice of
[INAUDIBLE] infrastructure
is also possible.
We intend to support
RHEL, CentOS, and Ubuntu.
And from a networking
standpoint,
N3 connectivity between
the nodes is required,
and we need L2 between
the load balancing nodes,
but Google provides an overlay
networking L4 and L7 node
balancing.
From a storage, you can
integrate with your storage
infrastructure using CSI.
Upgrade will be in place,
and from an observability
standpoint, of course
we have out of the box
Stackdriver [INAUDIBLE] Cloud
Monitoring metrics and logs.
Or you can integrate with the
customer-provided observability
if you want.
We're also considering
VM lifecycle options
with technologies like
KubeVirt and many others.
So this provides
you a very flexible
stack where you can deploy on
your existing infrastructure
and easily run
application using Anthos.
So in terms of managing
Anthos at the edge,
some of the technologies and
the capabilities that we have
makes it very easy to do so.
So we're going to
cover some of those.
So the first one is the
standardized architecture.
Again, you have the flexibility
to deploy on VMware,
deploy on your favorite
operating system.
So this gives you
tremendous flexibility
to deploy where you are and not
have to retrofit your existing
infrastructure.
In fact, you can leverage
your existing infrastructure
to meet your current
needs, and you can even
modernize it in place
without impacting the apps.
So that's the first piece of
the application modernization
managing [? of ?] [? it. ?] The
second is managing the entire
fleet, and one of the
challenges that I've seen a lot
of customers is they
have thousands of stores,
thousands of locations.
So managing across all of
these locations is very hard,
and having a cloud-based
monitoring solution
and management solution
helps you there.
So one of the technologies
is the single pane of glass
to have for your
clusters and workloads.
You can manage the cluster
from a single cloud-based web
console.
You have visibility
for your entire fleet,
no matter where they are.
And you can deploy workflows
from a private registry
or from a GCP marketplace,
all of this from a console
or a centralized API
through Google Cloud.
So this gives you great
flexibility and a single point
to manage and deploy
all your cluster.
The second part is centralized
logging and monitoring.
As you look across all
of these locations,
you need to understand
what's up, what's not.
You need to diagnose.
Sending a technician
can sometimes
be very costly and
very time consuming,
and have an impact
to the business
if you have a
store that is down.
Centralized logging
and monitoring
helps you with that by
aligning all of the data
and pushing it to Stackdriver,
or now Cloud Monitoring.
And then you can see
what's happening,
error rates, performance.
You can even manage the
lifecycle of those locations
and define SLO and monitoring
for your SRE codes and signals.
So that's from operations,
and then that gives you
the fleet-wide policy
management, again through--
do this from a kubectl.
You can also use GitOps.
So from a programmatic
SRE kind of standpoint,
you can use DevOps technologies.
You can have your
single team deploy,
for example, a canonical
version of the app, one place,
and it gets replicated
across all of your stores
in a matter of seconds.
So that also gives you
a lot of flexibility
of how to deploy apps
across the fleet.
So we want to talk about
edge deployment models here.
And one of the
interesting innovations
that we are introducing
to the market
as Google is, as a customer, you
don't have to manage or deploy
all the apps.
We give you different
options to do so.
So the first part
worth mentioning
is Google's global network.
And this is something that is
very unique to Google, not just
by our data centers
but our connectivity
to region, PoPs, and
networks that you've
used over the years
for Search, for YouTube
for Stadia and gaming.
So these are a combination
of CDN edge point presence,
dedicated interconnect, and even
cloud regions that gives you
a lot of flexibility on that.
So from that, we
have 24 regions.
We have 144 edge
PoPs and thousands
of edge nodes in
telecom networks.
But that's the part
that we are starting
to have innovation for it.
As you integrate with
existing telecom partners,
that gives you a lot of options
to expand our network even
further in this partnership and
gives you even closer points
of presence across the globe.
So this gives us a flexible
operation model for the edge.
So we have three
options that will
make your life a lot easier as
a customer to deploy the edge.
The first one is a
Google-managed edge.
In this case, you are
leveraging Google's capability,
Google's infrastructure, for
example like edge caching
and service nodes and using
edge point of presence
on Google Cloud, either core
regions and zones or edge
regions and zones.
So that's the first option.
The second option is telco
edge, leveraging our existing
partnership with
the telcos and using
their small central
office presence,
a large central office presence
to deploy this, for example.
So you don't even have
to have it on the store.
You can have using
a combination of 5G
and then have your equipment, or
actually the telco's equipment
running your application.
This gives you the ability
to deploy, for example,
next to your store.
So you don't have to have the
presence in the store itself,
but actually have
something that is
very close and very connected.
And finally, of
course, the customer
edge, the classical
customer edge scenario,
where you are deploying
on your existing branch
office or your existing
retail location.
And that gives you the
traditional presence
that you have, but also
gives you another option.
So between the
three options, that
gives you a lot of
flexibility on designing
your own infrastructure
to meet your needs
and the appropriate operational
model for your business.
For a sample edge architecture
and how the edge is evolving,
this is, for example, a real
time inventory management
and analytics architecture.
So if you build this
architecture just
on a cloud-only
kind of set up, this
is how it would
look like, where you
have the point of sale inventory
and RFID systems in the store,
but then you have a
lot of capabilities
in a cloud provider like
Google Cloud Platform,
using technologies like Cloud
Pub/Sub, aggregation analytics,
and video APIs.
But we also have in
this, what Anthos
gives you is a new architecture
where you can move in some
of those capabilities
to in-store,
again, to make it
closer to where you are,
so that you can leverage
your platform of your choice
and the services that
you need, but still
have the latency
and the sensitivity.
So again, flexibility
in the architecture
of how you build
your applications
gives you a lot
of options on how
you want to run your business.
So in terms of
innovation, our goal
is to help you with our
industry-specific solutions,
from retail, health care,
financial services, media
and telco, manufacturer,
and public sectors.
Across all of these,
there are many solutions
that are built out there,
best practices and expertise
within Google Cloud that we
can leverage and help you
to build your own
industry-specific solution.
So next, I would
like to introduce
a use case of using Anthos
at the edge with Major League
Baseball.
KRIS AMY: Thanks, Amr.
Thanks for having me here.
So I thought, what
better way to start
this whole section of the
presentation off than,
let's go through what an actual
end user experience is like.
So what we're seeing here is a
product that we call Game Day.
You go to MLB.com.
You click on a game.
You can see a sort of virtual
experience in a game here.
And what we're seeing
is play by play data.
We're seeing pitches
and how the pitches were
thrown, what the
velocity was, where
they were in the strike zone.
Then we get into what
actual plays happened.
Did a runner steal?
Was there a pick-off attempt?
Was there a home run hit?
And even that, we're loading
videos of key parts of the game
straight into the feed.
And so how does this
all come together?
We start off with our new
stack [? cos ?] tracking system
that we have for 2020.
This is a completely
new system that we've
developed and deployed.
It uses machine vision
with a whole stack
of cameras that pick
up velocity, spin
rate of the ball, where players
are, what their poses are,
and what's happening
in the game.
So what we're seeing
here is a pitcher
from the New York Yankees.
This is a video that we took
last year of them actually
throwing.
You can see how the ball--
we pick up the trajectory.
We can put it back in time to
work out where it came from
and where it's going
to be going through.
So how does this all work?
Well, as you know
in baseball, it all
starts with a pitcher
throwing a pitch.
So we kick it off.
We have an on-field
play that happens.
There's someone in the
stadium, all remote, who
clicks for the
start of the play,
and they complete the
play once it's finished.
Our tracking system is going
to absorb all the data and all
the events that are happening
throughout that play,
we aggregate it, and we process
it in stadium on Anthos.
So we collect all of
that data, we process it,
we set up a play, and then we
ship it up to Google Cloud,
or potentially in stadium if
we have other subscribers that
need that information for
low-latency reasons in stadium.
So where do we come from?
What do we do?
So in 2019, we had an aging
hardware stack in stadium.
You can see that on the right.
That's what the end
result looks like.
We had this aging hardware.
We were bringing a new
tracking solution coming in,
and we needed a way to
simplify, modernize, and bring
consistency to our on-premise
or in-stadium environment
to what we run in the cloud.
And we had to have
something that
would run there, be
stable, and enable
the throughput and the
latency requirements
that we have in stadium.
So what does our
environment look like?
Last year we virtually
had one virtual machine
for every application
we ran in the stadium.
It had some local
storage attached to it.
We packaged our apps with RMPs.
We had no real
automatic failover.
We had to run two
copies of everything,
because if we lost
one, we had no way
to automatically
stand it up and run it
by a second location
or anything else.
And if we had a burst
in the stadium where
we had to process
a whole lot of data
and potentially we were going
to resend a whole lot of data
from a game that
happened in the past,
and we want to get it
processed really quickly,
we had no way to
flexibly to scale up,
scale down as we needed.
So we come into 2020.
What do we do?
We took Anthos on prem.
We're running on top of VMware.
We made the decision that--
we saw Anthos as this
standardization for containers
for all of our
applications, regardless
of where we ran them, whether
that's in Google Cloud,
whether that's on prem,
or even in our stadiums.
We had this key requirement
for automatic failover
for our processing
of all worker nodes,
and we needed out
applications to be
able to horizontally
scale in the stadium,
just like they
would scale if we're
running on GKE in the cloud.
So our architecture,
it's probably
a little bit different
from your standard Anthos
on-prem architecture.
We have our admin
workstation that
runs inside GCP in the cloud.
And then for every ballpark,
we've got two here displayed.
We've got the Rockies
and the Marlins.
We don't have shared
storage in the park.
We basically have two
processing nodes that we run.
They run VMware.
And then on top of that,
they have local storage.
We run the Seesaw load balancer
setup for each cluster.
So we had each node.
It's its own cluster.
It has its own admin
cluster, the control
[? planes, ?] et cetera.
And then inside that actual
physical hardware machine,
we had the various worker
nodes that we need.
And in our case, we run
three different worker nodes.
So what's our end
user interaction?
We do all this processing
in stadium on Anthos.
Where does the data go?
We'll ship it to
in-stadium experiences.
So that could be up on
the scoreboard you'll see.
You know you can see
that at the score change,
or you see a pitch speed, or
what type of pitch it was.
We offload it to our broadcast
partners watching on TV.
And you see the pitch trajectory
or [? where ?] the home run
was hit, et cetera.
We also then take that data, and
we ship it up to Google Cloud,
where you get experience
from our digital properties
and products.
That's what we started
this whole session off with
was Game Day, which is one
of those digital properties
or products.
We also do advanced data
analytics on all this,
and we do AI and ML
to work out what's
going to be the new metric that
we're going to see come out
of baseball in 2020 or 2021?
So where do we go to from here?
I covered off just before what
we do right now on the web.
What we got loaded up
here is a rendering
of an actual play that
occurred virtually.
It's concepts around, what
can we do with this data
that we haven't ever thought of?
And this is where we see Anthos
is a key for our go forward
with all of our data that
we're shipping from the park.
So with that, I'd like
to throw it back to Amr.
Really great to be
here today, and really
excited to see what
Anthos can offer.
AMR ABDELRAZIK: Thank
you very much, Kris.
That was a very cool use case.
And as you have
seen, it demonstrated
the power of Anthos.
MLB team had a virtualized
infrastructure at the edge.
They deploy it.
It's the same infrastructure
that they deploy on the cloud,
and had the same infrastructure
as they migrate to bare metal.
So our goal with
Anthos is to bring
the same level of flexibility
and the power of Google Cloud
to the edge with
an open application
platform, flexible deployment
option, and a strong ecosystem.
So I encourage you all
to try Anthos on GCP.
You can see this link here.
The link has a lot
of tutorials, a lot
to demonstrate and try a lot
of the capabilities of Anthos.
And at the end, I just
want to thank you all
for giving us the time today.
We know it's a crazy world out
there, so we really appreciate
you taking the time to
learn about our technology
and our product, and we look
forward to partner and work
with.
You.
Thank you.